como uno de los momentos más dolorosos
de su carrera política me duele pero hay
que hacerlo por el bien de chile así
definió Gabriel borich esta tarde en una
ceremonia que comenzó una hora y media
con retraso con polémica en el medio el
nombramiento de un subsecretario de
interior que duró apenas una hora en el
cargo y con lágrimas También las de La
despedida de la ministra hasta ahora
ministro del interior es una figura muy
querida entre la ciudadanía chilena que
había sido también muy criticada en
estos primeros seis meses de mandato
como bien señalabas entra ahora Carolina
tajá una figura muy conocida de la
política chilena que fue ministra los
gobiernos de Michelle bachelet Y también
fue alcaldesa de Santiago una figura muy
destacada del partido por la democracia
también Analía Uriarte otra de las
figuras que entrará y se hará cargo de
las relaciones con el congreso en un
momento clave supone la entrada de una
mayor participación de la
socialdemocracia en el gobierno de
Gabriel borich que pertenece al partido
apruebo dignidad formado por el partido
comunista y el frente amplio esto le da
un balance y una mayor cohesión al
gobierno en un momento que necesita esos
balances para las negociaciones que se
vienen para lograr grandes
transformaciones en el país para
preocuparse por los temas que atacan de
cerca a la ciudadanía chilena la
inflación la delincuencia el déficit de
hogares Y muchas otras temas y también
para las negociaciones sobre el nuevo
proceso Constituyente que se quiere
iniciar en el país precisamente sobre
ese tema Patricia cómo avanza ese
proceso de un nuevo itinerario
Constituyente del que habló brecha
después de la derrota en el referéndum
del domingo
pues ese itinerario Constituyente al que
se refirió el presidente borich comenzó
el propio lunes en la moneda con reúna
reunión del oficialismo que realizó un
ejercicio autocrítica y continúa esta
tarde en una jornada clave a las 5 de la
tarde chilenas en apenas unos minutos
está prevista una reunión con el
oficialismo y también con la oposición
está en duda se iba a participar la
derecha que se manifestó a favor de
lograr un proceso para darle a Chile una
nueva constitución un texto que luego en
el acuerdo de todos los ciudadanos sin
embargo tanto la unión democrática
independiente la udi y la derecha más
dura sacando el partido republicano que
está en la parte más extrema y ha
manifestado que no va a participar y
renovación nacional otro de los partidos
importantes de derechos que sí había
dicho que iba a participar en la reunión
de esta tarde Afirma ahora que se va a
restar debido a toda la polémica que Se
generó con este nombramiento de un
subsecretario del interior que duró
apenas una hora y que fue rechazado por
estar vinculado en sus publicaciones de
Twitter con críticas a la policía
chilena Así que el ambiente está cargado
pero mucha expectativa en Chile por lo
que pueda ocurrir esta mañana había
manifestaciones de secundaria de
estudiantes de secundaria figuras que
son clave en los procesos de cambio en
Chile pidiendo al presidente que se
traduzcan los cambios sociales
demandados que se produzcan y que se
inicie un nuevo proceso Constituyente